Hey, good morning!
Our neighbors just came and gave us--
Juice!
Aaaand
Oh my god..
Damn
Woo, I can just smell the fat and sugar from--
*sniffs intensely*
Ooooh, daaamn
They look gooooood
Charcoal lemonade
WoAH
Oh, that's weird
I guess it's good for you? I don't--
I don't know?
I'd normally feel kinda weird 'cause they've obviously seen my vlogs
But they were so cool, soooo
I don't know
They weren't jumping with a camera (That's always good)
Trying to take pictures in our house, let's just say that
Feels so good with the weekend I finally have some time off
Me and Marzia are gonna hang out today, I'm really excited (AWWW)
But first I'm gonna go on a quick run
*SANIC FAST!*
I love running in another country
It's so interesting to, like
just look around and--
Oh my god
Are you trying to be Casey Neistat? (HAI GARBLE)
Co-come on Garble we're not doing that
*sighs dramatically*
*Garble Voice* But I love Casey!
Yes, he's cool but come on
*sniffs donut*
*dat sexy moan*
My mouth is just watering up like cra--
Marzia!
You gotta see these
*SNIFF*
Marzia: Did you taste them?
Pewds: No, I can't! Because they look like a million calories per bite (THEY LOOK GOOD)
Marzia: Try it, it's a donut
Pewds: *SNIIIIIIFF*
Marzia: Try it. I'll give it a try
Pewds: No, I'm not gonna--
*Pewds moans*
You gotta fix this. I can't go out like this
Marzia: What do you want me to do? These?
Pewds: Just fix it. I can-- I don't wanna walk around with a cat's butthole
Try and cover the penises
Marzia: With what?
Pewds: Something cute, make it into flowers
This is what you do you touch things and they become cute (CUTIEpiemarzia)
*laughing* Marzia: What?
A flower penis! Great! :D
That's so much better!
What did you do?
Marzia: I don't know
What is this? (HAHAH)
*Marzia laughing in the background*
You think that's funny? (it's kinda funny)
Look at--
Goddamit
Okay, so we're going to Little Tokyo now, or Bates Motel..?
Marzia's obsessed with Bates Motel, so
Pewds: You kids stay safe now!
(DAT FANCY MUSIC) :D
So excited for a good rum. (Drinking is bad Poods!)
We wrapped at, like, 4 AM last night, so I'm really tired (Poor Poods)
I just realized how bad I felt
*Fancy music...Again*
Pewds: *Sighs* Man..
It felt like we were drowning there for a second
We were getting stopped, like, every 5 seconds, and I was just like
Take me out of here *laughs*
Everyone was really sweet, but it gets too much
They're like '"can I take a picture,"  "can I take a picture," "can I take a picture?"
I think we need to get out of here...
*More music, but not the same music as before*
*Music fades*
I think Marzia's having a great time, but..I'm dying
I'm so tried
(Marzia's so cute ^_^)
Don't tell her though. I really wanna just sleep (Aww)
Marzia: What did you get?
Poods: I don't know, this is not it
What in the hell is this?
Marzia: You know you had two, right?
Poods: Yeah
I said that, like, "There was two, right?"
She was, like, "no."
What's this stupid thing?
Google..?
It's a pixel phone...
Mariza: Another one?
"Dear Felix, I wanted you to be one of the first people"
But I already used one for, like a month? *Marzia giggles in the background)
Marzia: There it is!
Pewds: Yeah, it's right there!
Thanks Suzan, from Google
I mean, I love the pixel, but..
I'm really disappointed that- I was expecting another package
So ungrateful! I got a pixel phone, but, like..*Laughs*
It's not what I wanted
I bet now that we're coming back..
We're gonna miss the new package
That always happens
Something that did arrive, though, waaaas
This!~
If you're not familiar with "Raspberry Pi," it's a very tiny computer
..And I'm gonna build it into a camera!
I don't know, I've never done it before, but I thought it might be cool
I'll probably fuck up, but here we go!
*Chill music*
Pewds: Alright, it's running
I'm gonna now try and do my first picture
With the camera
I'm excited
Enable camera...
Done!
No
Okay...
Re- I gotta reboot
This is cool
I'm excited
Here we go!
Hey!
Woah!
Shit!
I didn't expect that!
Okay..
Fuck
*Laughs*
Do you see this?
Okay..
Cameras working!
So, it's automatically gonna keep taking pictures. I'm really excited to test out some timelaps for Birdaboo
Now, I really gotta do something else, I spent too much time on this. But it's..
pretty cool!
Maria: really really really hungry!
Alright guys, Marzia's really hungry, so we're gonna go outside and eat
We're going..!
On this really creepy road
Marzia: As usual (o_o)
LA's so trashy!
Marzia: Whaaaaa!?
Pewds: Yeah, that's right LA! I called you out
C'mon, it looks-
It looks like we could get stabbed here
Marzia: Yep!
Pewds: You better stay close,Marzia!
I'll protect you!
Marzia: Thank you
Pewds: From all the stabbing people
Both: And cars
Pewds: Okay,let's run
Let's run, they're dangerous
You don't wanna die, Marzia
That's why I'm here
alright anyway
So, anyway
Uh, this vlog has not been the most exciting,maybe
but, it's been a nice chill day
And, uh, you know what I think I really need right now?
Marzia: A burger!
Pewds: A vegan, uh, burger
I'm always scared crossing the street in LA
I guess we're supposed to go?
There's no light
What do we do!?
We're just supposed to go,in this?!
A "baaadasss"...
We'll have that one
Marzia: but that's Breakfast?
Pewds: ...Shit
Alright...We got an extra sandwhich
because they recognized us (lucky >.>)
Thank you very much!
It is really cool how you get-
You know, a lot of you guys are very nice and..
and polite and give us free shit
I appreciate it!
I was a little sad though, that today-I couldn't really enjoy going to Little Tokyo
because I felt-I felt like people were watching me every second
like I kept getting stopped constantly
I don't know, that kinda ruins it for me a little bit
So it is, you know, potato pototo
you know what I-motato?
Alright, I set it up over the night
It's probably gonna look shit because I haven't gotten a battery for it yet
So I have to put it there
I just wanna test it out
But it kinda feels like fishing a little bit
Like, you have to place down and see what you get
I'll seeya tomorrow, buddy
*Transition music*
Pewds: Alright, well, I had a lovely day with Marzia
Pewds: Really good time, I think it'll be a really entertaining vlog
Brad:What do you think the title and thumbnail will be?
Pewds: Earthquake!
Brad: Earthquake?
Pewds: Yeah, there's gonna be an earthquake
Brad: Apparently, there's gonna be an earthquake
Pewds: There's gonna be an earthquake
Brad: That's why we're stood outside
Pewds: Because we need a title
Brad: because we need the title and thumbnail
Pewds: and we've been praying to Mother Nature
Brad: this section needs a name, doesn't it? title and thumbnail
Pewds: Yeah, yeah
Pewds: *Sings* it's time for title and thumbnail with me and Brad!
Brad: How to Youtube!
Brad: how to Youtube
Brad: Get any content you want and lie about the thumbnail and title
Pewds: Because that's the most important bit!
Brad: and that's the most important--That's "How To Youtube 2016"
Pewds: You can enjoy the video as much as you like, but if people ain't clicking on it, it don't mean shit!
Brad: Right?
Brad: I'm triggered
Pewds: You feel that?
Brad: I do feel that, what is it?
Pewds: I think it's coming!
Brad: Oh my god!
Pewds: It's the first California earthquake!
*Intense shaking*
Pewds: Ugh!
Pewds: How is the camera so stable?
Brad: That was scary
Brad: Earthquake thumbnail
Pewds: How's that?
Pewds: Is that good?
Pewds: This way?
Woman: Tiny bit
Woman: Perfect!
Pewds: Is that the money shot?
Brad: Money shot!
Pewds: money shot!
Brad: and that's how you do Youtube!
Pewds: thanks FouseyTube!
Brad: thanks Fousey!
alright another day, another Birdabo!
I hope I didn't give you guys mixed messages about
uh meeting
in person
if you ever see me
I want you to come and say hi
I really do
uhm I'm just trying to
like I said I want Birdabo to be honest vlogs
and I'm just trying to
explain my perspective on things
I hope you understand
but regardless,
Thank you guys so much for watching (and reading!)
another episode
and I'll see you tomorrow
with another one!
and as always *Brofist*
*Jazzy outro music*